[Music]
yeah let's actually play maybe we can
play somebody lower rated um
like a sub
so maybe somebody in like the 13 1500
range if you guys want
it's been because i've been i've been
doing pretty high rated
tommy if you want a game
i can give you i can give you a game but
10 minutes
or 10 or 15 minutes
all right tommy let's go
wow he's very underrated
let's go with the d4
let's go d4
okay d45 we're gonna play
beth harmon style queen's gambit
we are go okay dc so
how to play in this position this is the
queen's gamut accepted it is not a bad
opening
um very very popular at the highest
level white has a couple of ways to
respond here
um
essentially the lines are divided into
two categories one is you can play the
move pawn to e3
the upside of that move is that d4 is
better protected the downside is that
obviously the bishop is blocked but the
most ambitious way to respond is and
this has become the most popular move in
recent years and that is e4
e4 is the natural move um obviously it
leaves these pawns pretty exposed
there's a lot of theory here
but if black is not careful
uh black could get in very serious
trouble here if we just recover the pawn
we'll have a beautiful center so
all of black's main lines
consist of moves that essentially attack
these two puns as quickly as possible
yeah one of the moves is actually to
play e5 and offer up a counter sacrifice
knight c knight f6 is one of the one of
the top moves
okay so here the old move is to go
knight c3
but after knight c3 black plays e5 i'll
show you this after the game
and that line is not considered good for
white
um
i mean it's it's not great black
equalizes comfortably
so what we want to do here is actually
go
e5 thank you gotta for the raid much
appreciated
good time to join
yeah bishop three
and now we recover the pawn of bishop
dixie for this is theory i had a game
like this with jeffrey zhang in the u.s
championship
what does the battle revolve around in a
position like this well both sides
have their advantage we have a very nice
pawn center we have a space advantage
black has control over this key square
in d5
so the battle is going to revolve around
whether white is able
uh to
essentially get control of the square if
we get control of the d5 square black is
going to be in trouble almost instantly
bishop f5 yeah that is
and i'm not too well versed in the
theory myself
um there's also a lot of tactical
subtleties here
i don't think bishop f5 is correct i
think the move is to go knight b6
yeah so queen b3 looks like it
essentially ends the game but i don't
believe it does
because if you follow this line queen b3
he goes e6
and then if we grab this pawn
black can simply go knight d7 and get a
very big development advantage in return
for the pun i actually don't want that
pawn i want to focus on what's important
which is to get control of the d5 square
so i'm proposing either 92 followed by
knight bc3
or the immediate knight c3 let's go
maybe with the immediate
but maybe knight c3 he's got some knight
before action
so
let's go actually
let's go 92 let's just develop the
knight
and then go knight b c3 i'm gonna play
this calmly
all right
yeah g4 would be just a one move thread
that would weaken the king's side we
don't want that
why doesn't the knight be long in f3
that's a great question
the longs
there are a couple of reasons one is
that he could always go bishop g4 and
pin the knight
whereas if we go 92 bishop g4 is not
dangerous due to
f3 um the other reason is that this
knight can you know defends its its
brother on c3
and that plays more into our general
idea of controlling d5
there should be four
remember save your specific questions
for after the game it should be four is
a good move it doesn't create any
threats
um
this check does not do anything just
develops the knight to c6
um
so we shouldn't do anything special all
we should do is castle here we're just
developing our pieces
and now queen v3 is quite a serious idea
because it hits the bishop it pressures
the knight
um so queen b3 is something black will
have to be very careful about
c6
solid tommy is playing
pretty decent chess here i think black
is worse but
not much worse
okay what to do here um
a couple of approaches that we could
take
i really like the move queen b3 i feel
like it puts very significant pressure
on black's pieces knight g3 is not
playable here
or maybe actually it is oh
now that i think about it i think knight
g3 is playable
and
more than playable it's very very
interesting
okay let's do it
so
i'm going to play this move and then
after the game i'm going to walk you
through the logic
of how i was able to
figure out that it's playable knight g3
looks like a blunder
why does it look like a blunder because
black can play knight takes c3 bc bishop
takes c3 not only have we lost a pawn
our rook in the corner is also trapped
but
i forced myself to calculate a little
bit deeper than that so i saw this
position in my mind after bishop c3
and
i figured out that
the rook being trapped does not tell the
whole story remember that black is
uncastled
and we have contact between the knight
and the bishop there's also a very weak
square on d6
if we occupy that score of the knight
we're going to get a pretty devastating
attack so
what we want to start with
is knight takes f5 simple move
if he takes the rook we don't even
really need to calculate that we can go
knight d6 with devastating compensation
this is the move that i think is quite
critical
and i think here we have a very pretty
move
we have a very very pretty move what are
the options
option one is bishop takes f7 a lot of
you
i think are excited about this tactic
king takes f7
queen b3 and we recover the bishop with
a big advantage for sure great great
idea
logical
but let's not limit ourselves to that um
do we really want to give away this
bishop there is quite a typical idea
here that i've seen in the italian
rather than taking on f7 immediately we
can prepare bishop takes f7 with a
double attack
the move queen b3
i think is very very promising
and we are sacking the rook but
essentially it's a fork we are forking
the pawn on f7 and the bishop on c3
um
it's pretty easy to calculate the
variations here bishop takes a1 bishop
takes f7
and if the king steps into this diagonal
bishop a3 is just checkmate
this is
pretty thematic stuff if you've played
the italian you should be familiar with
a similar line in the italian
this is an advanced fork but
this is not this is something that comes
with experience you know understanding
that this is totally devastating black
is completely undeveloped here
and we've got all of our pieces in the
attack
yeah bishop takes a one push takes f7
the most resilient is kd7 but there we
have a move
and now the king is totally trapped
boxed in box box bishop a3
okay
and he resigns good game
yeah after queen e7 if we want to win
the fastest way possible queen e6
is the most clinical move
and the prettiest queen of xa 3.8 e8
check me
okay
good game tommy
that's what you get for trolling
okay so e4
knight f6 is one of many moves
um first important point
is that knight c3 allows e5 very nasty
um
very very nasty
you might say wait a second just take
the pawn attack tonight but if you
follow this line queen takes d1 white is
in a tough situation here
you don't want to take with the knight
and give the e4 pawn
you certainly don't want to take with
the king and allow knight you for now
you don't have castling rights the
knight comes around
and takes the pawn white is actually
just worse here
um yeah i'll show the italian line in a
second
therefore we go e5 knight t5 bishop
takes c4
and if if memory serves me right
the the cool people tommy's not included
in that category go knight v6 they step
away immediately
to take the sting out of the move queen
b3 and knight c3
all right
we'll see a note
okay
so
is this the line that graco no so he
goes bishop f5
which is not a terrible move just to
show queen b3 here oh yeah what about
queen f3
queen f3 allows e6 and i think black
defends everything
so forks can often be defended against
with these individual pawn moves thank
you or drone
and bishop takes d5 obviously this loses
a piece but black and play queen takes
d5
so these kinds of moves don't
don't work queen b3 e6 queen takes b7
and probably the most accurate here is
to go
knight p6 or even knight d7
and this is a this is a very instructive
line because here i can win a second
pawn you're you're probably looking at
this saying wait a second
bishop takes d5 e takes d5 queen takes
d5 and i'm sure white is better here
objectively but
look at this another way black has a big
development advantage two bishops
why go into a position like this when
you can play
uh in a perfectly sound positional
manner thank you ace
791 before check this is a little bit
nasty i don't like when the queen is the
only piece that's developed
so
be careful about hunting for pawns like
this when you don't have other pieces
developed and also don't overestimate
this situation very rarely is the stroke
actually trapped
i see a lot of people go into this thing
ah the rook is trapped but because the
queen
makes contact of the rook this move
often just saves everything
um and even sometimes black can give up
the rook and the trap the queen there's
many lines like this many lines like
this
so just file this away into your mental
uh tactical toolkit i can give you an
example
in the nimzo indian
this is a random opening but i'm just
showing you this because of the
variation there's a line here
um
there's a line here
where
let me try to remember it actually
yeah so essentially sorry
can i remember it
no it's not like this
just give me a second
why am i having am i having trouble
remembering it
there's a line where black gives up the
rook that rook on a8
but um anyway i can't remember right now
for some reason
um so
but anyway there are many lines like
this it doesn't really matter
back to the game thank you jiggly
piggles for the prime
okay so bishop b4 castles
um already black is worse
and tommy goes c6 which i kind of like i
think this move supports the knight on
d5 yeah y92 so as i was explaining
knight f3
looks like a more active developing move
but here the knight does not support the
c3 score
from e2 it's also able to go to f4 so
everything here revolves around getting
control of the square
it's very important to understand this
so when you look at a developing move
don't just say 92 is inferior to knight
f3 that's
often not the case
92 is just an alternate way of
developing that has its pros and cons
if that makes sense
so e6 knight c3 bishop b4 castle c6
and now this move knight g3 now which is
the line in the italian this one i do
remember
why doesn't knight b4 work here knight
before probably does work actually
um to be honest i i overlooked
i overlooked this um i think we castle
here
after knight c2 i'm going to tell you
something insane
i think we can sacrifice that rook and
the computer confirms this
uh we can go
knight g3
we can go knight g3
and
we just give the rook up and this is a
very similar line this position is
winning for white look at black's
development just e6 this is crushing
who cares about the stroke white's got
everything in the attack black can
resign here
and i'm not calculating any variations
just look at black's king everything's
collapsing
big reason why black is lost here is
because black doesn't have a light
square bishop
um here you can very clearly see
the problem of having a weakness on a
bunch of squares of the same colors like
black will never be able to castle
some positions don't need to be spelled
out they can just be understood
um this is where intuition comes in so
knight g3
i'm not gonna pretend i saw this i
didn't
um black can play bishop g6 here and
here the computer suggests an amazing
move bishop g5
who can figure out
who can figure out what the idea is
after queen takes g5 amazing amazing
concept
i've talked about this in a on a speed
run very long ago um
when there is a very big distance
between two pieces such as a bishop
defending a knight the wider the
distance
uh the more
opportunity there is for an interference
tactic the more opportunity there is for
an interfere what is an interference
factor when you put a piece in the
middle whoa chess bra rating 788
welcome guest so i'm analyzing my
speedrun game with tommy
you guys coming a great time thank you
so much eric you're the man
um welcome chess bras
we are doing some speed running i'm
going to be teaching box box pretty soon
hope you guys stick around
welcome
everybody yeah that's right brandon the
so i'm talking about an interesting
moment in the game with tommy
where we have this insane tactic knight
ce4
intercepting the defense of the bishop
on the knight the queen has to move
queen takes c2 and white is a great
position here
despite the fact that black is pinning
the knight this is well protected
another reason to put the knight on e2
it can go to g3
so i think knight before was the best
practical chance but tommy goes bishop
before
right square wrong piece
and here knight g3
how did i see this move well there is a
famous line in the italian
i feel like amman probably has shown
this
what is this line it's a it's a line in
the classical italian it's been around
for
literally 400 years
geekino graco
first
i think um proposed this line
and it's this is the classical italian
you sacrifice the fun i'm sure you guys
have seen this before and here you
castle
now the modern move is to take on c3
with the bishop
but if you haven't seen this before
you're looking at this saying what if i
just take with a knight
and take on c3
and this is a very similar situation to
the one that occurred in my game if you
fast forward here
bishop on c3 bishop on c4 weak pawn and
f7 you can recognize the pattern
and again a lot of you i'm sure are
tempted by bishop takes f7 this looks
cool
and it's not a bad move queen b3 the
king is uh devoid of castling rights
white is
white is doing amazing here
but
you don't play bishop f7 you play queen
b3 this is the winning move
bishop takes a1 bishop takes f7 and it's
not exactly the same
because here if you if you play bishop
a3 black has d6 so bishop a3 is a
mistake
but here the bishop has a different
square what should white do here who can
tell me this is the crushing move it's
just a slightly different approach to
the position
bishop g5 goodbye queen
97 rookie one and everything collapses
here
uh if black tries d6 and black basically
says hey i'm going to give you my queen
um
for two rooks
white has an amazing move here bishop g8
look at this
enlarging the diagonal for the queen
rook takes j now the rook is in the
queen's crosshairs now you take on e7
and in the end the rook hangs white is
crushing winning everything this is
really cool
i don't know i don't remember if graco
gave bishop g8 but
um there's there's alternate wins here
it's just really really cool stuff
if black plays knight takes d4
trying to
short-circuit
white's mechanism here you give a check
on a3 this is a very important check and
then you take the queen
so
this is a famous line in the italian
it's been around for many many years
that's why i always tell my students
um you shouldn't discount games like top
games or
you know those of you from the chest you
know eric is playing a game and the hab
armand is playing a game of the habits
speed run
and he plays an opening that you don't
play don't just roll your eyes and close
the close the tab try to engage with
that opening because you learn ideas
that you can apply to other openings
this is actually a very big part of
why i think some players are successful
you don't have to play an opening to
know its ideas and then to borrow them
and apply them to your own opening
maybe i'm making too big of a deal with
this but so tommy takes
and this is a slightly different entry
if bishop takes a one then knight d6
check is completely crushing here for
example we can play bishop a3 the
computer gives bishop take c6 which is
the strongest move
very simple tactics queen comes to f7
checkmate
yeah tommy had 996
ef5 and same idea boom boom boom here we
play bishop a3 and it's literally just
checkmate
if king d7
then we play queen takes b7 queen c7 we
obviously don't take the rook we go e6
the king is the worst defender boom boom
it's winning
so that was a very instructive game i
think
does anybody have questions from which
opening did this arise this was the
queen's gambit accepted
no bishop f6 is impossible there's a
pawn here
um
what if bishop takes d4 after queen b3
asks j beast if bishop takes d4 then um
bishop f7 king f8
and here probably bishop a3 checks c5
just queen takes b7 i mean here this is
slightly more resilient for black but
black's position is still falling apart
um
so this is completely crushing
[Music]
you